ja meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das thüringer parlament hat mit einer
knappen mehrheit mir den auftrag erteilt
zukünftig als ministerpräsident
verantwortung für den freistaat
thüringen zu tragen
ein kabinett zu bilden vorweg gestimmt
die arbeit beginnt jetzt möchte noch mal
betonen den dank an den
ministerpräsidenten ramelow
wer sich für das land eingesetzt hat und
auf eine begebenheit am heutigen
vormittag verweisen war warum sind der
fraktion und hat nochmals betont dass
wir als demokraten alle gefragt sind
spaltung in diesem land zu überwinden
und dafür verantwortung zu übernehmen
dass wir politik im sinne der bürger im
sinne der aufgaben des freistaates in
gemeinsamer staatlicher verantwortung
machen
die ersten eindrücke nach meiner wahl
spontane demonstrationen tierarten in
den sozialen medien drohanrufe machen
mich bestürzt und ich hoffe dass die
überwiegende zahl der thüringer das
genauso wie wir freie demokraten wie ich
persönlich ablehne
unsere aufgabe ist es nun ein
vielfältiges orientiertes kompetentes
kabinett zu bilden
ich werde eine einladung aussprechen cdu
spd und grüne sich der staatspolitischen
verantwortung zu stellen und gemeinsam
lösungen für thüringen zu suchen
schon nach der wahl ende oktober letzten
jahres war klar dass die
mehrheitsbildung in thüringen nicht
einfach werden wird
es war auch relativ schnell klar dass
eine regierung mit einer minderheit
versehen die geschicke dieses land
leiten kann
wir haben damals schon angeboten eine
minderheitsregierung aus der mitte des
parlaments aus der mitte der
gesellschaft zu bilden diesen auftrag
haben wir nunmehr im werden wir
nachkommen
ich denke die stärkung des parlaments
die immer wieder betont worden ist ist
unsere gemeinsame verantwortung aber
auch die gemeinsame möglichkeit positive
sie diesem land zu verändern spaltung zu
überwinden und die aufgeputschte
stimmung die auch heute ich dir heute
wieder leben dürfen wieder einzufangen
und durch sagt orientierte lösungen
lösungen für thüringen für bessere
bildung für eine freie wirtschaft sollte
prosperierende wirtschaft eine gute
infrastruktur für sicherheit und ordnung
all die dinge sind unsere aufgaben
sie werden es sehen
es wird keine fdp parteipolitik gemacht
es wird politik für die menschen in
thüringen gemacht werden
dankeschön
wir werden nochmals gesagt einladungen
aussprechen an cdu spd und grüne und im
ergebnis dieser gespräche die
entscheidungen treffen
es war eine geheime wahl unter drei
kandidaten dass die afd
so agiert wie reagiert hat können sie
selber bewerten ich kann nur nochmals
betonen die brandmauern gegenüber die
afd bleiben bestehen mit einem
ministerpräsidenten kemmerich wird es
kein angebot keine koalition keine miss
ministerien und auch keine afd politik
geben was wir vor der wahl gesagt haben
dass wir mit den extremen aus beiden
politischen lagern nicht zusammenarbeit
bleibt auch nach der wahl bestehen auch
am heutigen tage und auch die für die
zeitnahme schuldig ich habe meine ist
habe ich dazu gesagt ist eine geheime
wahl und offensichtlich versucht die afd
das so der ein oder andere jetzt es mir
unterstellen muss wir haben keine
kooperation keine absprache nichts mit
der afd
wenn sie versucht das amt des
ministerpräsidenten und meine wahl damit
zu beschädigen
hat sie mit mir einen erbitterten gegner
gewählt für die politik da fd ich bin
anti afd ich bin an die hacke herkommen
also die spd wird mit ihnen keine
koalitionsgespräche führen
zumindest nicht unsere derzeitigen
führung wie wollen sie die anträge im
parlament durchkommen nur mit der cdu
wird es nicht reichen
die frage stellt sich seit dem 27
oktober im parlament gibt es nicht das
was wir im politischen geübten
zusammenspiel als mehrheiten natürliche
art kennen
ich denke es geht mehr als den je um die
sache und wenn wir überhaupt über
inhalte uns an problematik hin an
lösungsansätze nähern dann sind all
diejenigen die auch an cdu und an die
fdp in den letzten wochen und monaten
gerichtet
auf forderungen gestellt haben sich der
verantwortung zu stellen der
staatspolitischen die verantwortungs
aufforderung geben jetzt zurück wir
müssen thüringen in der sache voran
bringen und da steht alle der parteien
cdu spd und grüne mit in der
verantwortung von günstige lösung von
thüringen zu machen und das parteibuch
hinten anzustellen und ideologie hinein
zu stellen die brandort zu den extremen
im politischen terror ist auf beiden
seiten gegeben
ich möchte nicht vergleichende dinge
anstellen wenn sie mich zur linken
konkret befragen auch sie haben in ihrer
programmatik dinge die nicht in meinen
augen mit der sozialen marktwirtschaft
mit den grundsätzen unserer demokratie
vereinbar sind
ich habe mich in einer geheimen
abstimmung thüringer landtag gestellt
das ist das gute recht eines demokraten
ich habe die kandidatur unternommen
nachdem feststand dass ein kandidat der
linken und eine kandidat der rechten
ausschließlich den thüringer bürgern als
wahlangebot zur verfügung standen und
haben die letzten tage immer wieder
gesagt die demokratische mitte muss hier
flagge zeigen
das haben wir getan ist eine partei die
es gerade so geschafft hat wir sind uns
ganz nach zählen nun den
ministerpräsidenten stellt ich das
zumindest etwas was beispiellos in der
geschichte ist also wie fühlen sie sich
damit
jedes mandat was die thüringer wähler
und wählerinnen am 27 oktober teilt
haben ist gleich stark
deshalb haben wir das gleiche mandat
habe ich das gleiche mandat wie die
übrigen 89 abgerufen sauber kann ich
heute nicht sagen wir werden heute noch
in gespräche eintreten und das natürlich
im sinne der aufgaben in thüringen auch
mit der nötigen schnelligkeit
vorantreiben aber wir lassen uns auch
nicht treiben
wir werden keinerlei politik mit der afg
betreiben in keiner denkbaren formen
nein die wahl zum beispiel die spd auf
total positionen gehen will nicht mit
ihrem kandidaten
verstehen sie dass wir das noch nicht
abschließend klären können weil da zählt
tatsächlich vor allem die kompetenz und
die bereitschaft der us- ansprechen
werde die nächsten tage das ist
mehrstufiges verfahren und ich würde dem
jetzt nur vorweg greifen aber
tatsächlich angedacht ist auch experten
in die regierung einzubinden ohne
parteibuch kemmerich was hat ihr
bundesvorsitzender lindner denn zu dem
wahlausgang gesagt hat er ihn schon
gratuliert hat mir gratuliert und gute
nerven gewünscht